bap bap bap it's very hard to listen to
my neighbors complain about being bored
when they still haven't cleaned out
their garage cuz I got we are so bored I
have cleaned up the yard sale
that is your garage the eyesore we all
have to look at everyday maybe move your
car from the lawn to the driveway
because it's been on the lawn for four
years now probably takes like 30 seconds
so stiff as long as you're bored why
don't you take this time to train your
dog because it barks all day and
attacks me every time I walk by your
home maybe take down the tarp
that brings down the property value of
the entire neighborhood just an idea all
right see you